okay step one thumbs up identified
constants and variables happy times okay
now we have to state some equations to
relate all of these guys together
because at the moment they're just all
sitting there and have nothing to do
with each other okay
so I need an equation that relates X
sorry X H and M sorry X H and ten what
am I going to use I sort of alluded to
it before Pythagoras because this is a
right angle triangle I didn't say it was
a vertical wall but you kind of assume
good construction and that kind of thing
so I'm going to say x squared plus h
squared equals ten squared and I might
as well so you know this is Pythagoras
so yeah why not why not
so I've stated a relevant equation it's
a measurement equation Pythagoras
relates all of these measurements
together but what am I trying to head
towards I'm gonna I'm about to determine
some derivatives and that kind of thing
but I want to work out what's the
trajectory where am I going the question
says how fast is the top of the ladder
moving okay that's what it is in words
can you translate that verbal question
into symbols what's the derivative I'm
hunting after in my scheme have a look
yeah it's the H or DT right that's what
the question is now if I'm after dhrd t
question mark and I know DX on DT what
is that how do I determine which
derivative will link those together have
a look yeah I want have a look this is
where I'm going I want D H on the top
and D T on the bottom I've got a DX on
the top so I'm gonna have to switch that
around that means I'm going to need D H
on DX does that make sense okay so if
that's the case how am I going to
rewrite this equation what am I gonna do
here I'm gonna make H the subject so and
you can see the reason why right accion
you notice is the HS at the top that's
the function you're differentiating and
the X is the variable you're
differentiating with respect to so it
goes over on the right hand side whoops
I haven't taken the square root yet what
do I got here 100 takeaway x squared
right you
notice at this point you can only take
one value of the square root but why is
that because I really should have a plus
or minus there why don't I have to
because H is our length right so I can
say H is greater than zero you might
also notice that's the not the only
restriction on H H can't just be
whatever it likes it also has to be less
than ten but that's not relevant to this
particular restriction okay so now that
I've got this I can actually
differentiate can someone tell me what
you actually get what do you get after
you use chain rule on this thing
negative x on square root of 100 minus x
squared so you've got that negative 2x
which is on the inside but it gets
multiplied by a half because this is a
hundred minus x squared to the power of
1/2 you okay with that you see how much
of knowledge you're having to pull on to
do this question what was the point
again a derivative why did I do it yeah
I can string together these two
derivatives now to get the actual
derivative them I'm after right I can
say D H on DT equals I should write my
chain rule step here it's a really
important one D H on DX the derivative I
just calculated times DX on DT the
constant rate of change that was given
to me in the question excuse me so
you're going to get an equation out of
this it looks like it's just going to be
minus 4x on this so what's the final
step to actually answer the question I'm
just going to substitute 6 into that and
you get dots are off what you get when x
equals 6 d H on DT equals negative 3
which you should interpret as saying
where is it here we go this top of the
ladder is 40 right it's it's height is
decreasing at a rate of 3 meters per
second okay
so it is a bit counterintuitive right
it's different to the rate of changing
out here and in fact as you can see when
X changes this rate also changes right
does it get faster or does it get
faster or slower now you could of course
just put some numbers in and find out
right it's kind of interesting because
you're like oh this is a quadratic but
you're taking a square root but you can
test out the numbers and you can see it
okay which is by the way why think about
it if a ladder is mounted up against the
wall right and it starts to fall when it
hits the ground is it gonna make a bag
or is it gonna land really nice and
softly as it lands on the ground what's
gonna land with a bang right which means
all that impact where does it come from
it comes from the fact that this thing
is gonna get faster and faster and
faster until it actually impact make
sense okay now just lastly Michael can I
pinch your piece of paper for a second
now what I loved is what I loved about
all of these kinds of questions is that
there are multiple ways to do this and I
sort of um I looked at Michaels for a
second and sort of looked at the
sideways because uh it was very
different to mine but what's lovely
about it is it still works so you don't
need to write this down if you don't
want to but I think it's kind of cool
what what Michael has done is if you
have a look at this right everything is
in terms of X's you okay with that right
so it's all in terms of where am I
looking here we go
this distance here the distance from the
wall that's what X is right but you
don't have to state it in terms of X
Michael said it in terms of x so he
wrote this and I wonder if you can um
think about what this means because I
have a line that's very similar to that
in my working it's here what's he done
here's he is pretty much it's it's
almost this exact same line except for
the fact that he said I don't need to
have X in terms of just that distance I
want to think about this in terms of
time so he's done something we did
yesterday with the balloon and said well
if you start the ladder off right at the
base of the wall as time progresses
right it just gets four meters further
and further way four and then eight it
all never get to twelve but you get the
idea right so that's how it's growing
now as he does that he does the same
thing that we do he makes H the subject
but he's
to get a different derivative not that
he's gonna say D H on DT and he works it
out to be here we go did you fix your
numbers he did you did yep you've got
one of his pens that Rob's out that's
handy he's gonna get this I'm gonna put
this on the denominator for you if
that's okay hmm that's you okay now when
you have a look at this again look at my
bottom line here do you see they aren't
saying the same thing just see that
except instead of saying X a distance he
said there's the minus 4 times 40 on the
top and there's the 40 that's been
squared does that make sense so it's all
in terms of time which is kind of nice
if time is what you're interested in
okay
his last thing is he has to work out
what time thank you he has to work out
what time the ladder hits the bottom of
the ground
sorry no he doesn't he has to work out
what time the bottom is 6 meters from
the wall right how does he work that out
how long does it take to get that far
thinking about how fast it's moving
these are intentionally simple numbers
so you can just look at it is it going
to take one second no that's not long
enough it'll only be for meat it's gonna
take two seconds no that's too far now
it's 8 meters away what's gonna be in
between it's exactly 1/2 seconds right
so instead of putting in when x equals 6
he puts in when T equals 1.5 and he gets
out he'll get out the same negative 3
that we did okay just as a point of our
difference the reason why this is
probably a most straightforward way is
because you never get told any x in this
question right you see that like I never
give you a T equals out equals whatever
but it still works and Michael has made
the you know logical working which is
consistent with what we've already done
okay